welcome to the
third lecture of 309.1
let's get started today is a very
exciting day because
we are going to discover
the electron together that's our goal
today
it's right there discovery of the
electron
and we're going to start talking about
models of the atom before we do that
i want to count i want to count because
that's what we did on friday
and and we'll use this problem actually
twice today
um by the way like if i do a problem
in class and it's like in a goody bag
and stuff
i don't know it might be the kind of
thing you might be asked on the quiz
i'm just saying um so so that's good to
know
i if i ask you this question because we
counted on friday we learned how to
count
and we learned about the mole in
avogadro's number and how that gets us
into and out of the atomic world
right so if i say how many gallium atoms
are in this strip of gallium
well we can do that now right because
well
how do you start this is where you start
and you're all taking it with you
everywhere now remember on friday we
talked about
how you got to bring it with you
everywhere
and tweet about it and send me pictures
and all that i need the density
right i need the density density and the
periodic table let's start with the
density
so if i have the density of gallium
and i look that up as 5.9 grams per
centimeter cubed
okay that's good well you know from the
strip i can measure it
with the super most accurate ruler in
the world that you have now
in your hands from the goody bag and you
see those are the measurements
and and so from and so if you measure it
you have a volume
uh okay it's those three numbers
multiplied i won't write it out it's 0.5
centimeters cubed and so now with the
density and the volume
i get that that strip has 2.95 grams
okay now that sounds pretty good it's
promising
but i want the number of atoms right
i want the number of atoms and that's
where again
you go to here because in there is the
grams
per mole and also the atomic mass units
which as we talked about friday are the
same thing
right and so if i look that up
i have that for gallium
we have 69.7
to grams per mole
right and so that means that in
2.95 grams
i have 2.95
divided by that number 69.723
let's raise this up a little which
equals
0.0423 moles i still
have not answered the question because
the question says how many atoms
right but that's where n sub a
or the mole or this this dozen
right but it's not a dozen it's a much
bigger number but this number
avogadro's number comes in and so in
that strip
of gallium ah no
in that strip of gallium you've got
you know in the ga strip
you've got uh 0.0423
times n a
atoms
that's something like you know 2.5
times 10 to the 22nd atoms that's a lot
of atoms in that strip but i was able to
do
but the the secret is the the right
remember
one atomic mass unit
gets you back and forth between one gram
per mole and by the way the atomic mass
unit is
is nothing it's just a mass unit
but i mean one amu happens to be by the
way
uh oh roughly 1.66
times 10 to the minus 27
kilograms oh that works
because now you can multiply this by a
whole mole and
it's a gram back and forth okay
good counting starting with counting
we're gonna end with counting
but in between we're gonna discover
something
beautiful because last week
okay the thesis of this whole class
remember is electronic structure holds
the key to everything
everything in your life can be
understood if you understood the
electronic structure of the elements
week one last week well we talked about
this we built it on friday
we talked about elements we did a few
reactions we talked about balancing
uh we made sure we have enough nitrogen
to grow plants for 100 million more
years
limited reagents this week
we're going to answer the question why
are these things different
we're switching gears right we know that
there are these indivisible atoms now we
built a whole table of them
right mendeleev but now we want to know
why they're different from one another
what causes that difference and that
starts with
the discovery of the electron and really
this this is such so we started la
let's write this here we'll have this
board
this is such a great story
this is a detective story that starts
with an atom looking
so these are like adam
models
okay so back in uh oh let's say
18 okay 460 if it's democritus
it's 460 bc and then remember we sort of
went all the way to
uh dalton who in 1803
he said yup democritus we're going with
that
we're going with that and uh oh there
are these indivisible things called
atoms so that was 1803.
but we need to understand them in order
to explain
this we need to understand them and it's
so this is a detective story
it's a detective it's one of the
greatest ones ever
ever ever played out in science it led
to
nothing less than the understanding of
all of nature
okay now how did it start well it
started
with jj thompson now so jj thompson
um by the way he won the nobel prize for
this discovery
he's he's credited with discovering the
electron also
seven of his students won the nobel
prize
that's cool and i remind my graduate
students of that
all the time without trying to put any
pressure on them
how did he do it well you see
he had these things there's his lab
there's thompson there's his lab
and these things were around they're
called cathode ray tubes
cathode ray tubes what do they do right
what do they do well your grandparents
would know
something about them i'll talk about
that in a few minutes but thompson
thompson was interested
in seeing what he saw on this thing here
and that's the photographic plate so
what we're going to do is
i'm just going to draw the cathode ray
tube i'm going to draw it
as best i can here so there's a cathode
ray tube
and over here we've got
a cathode and over here
we've got an anode so this would be a
cathode
and this here is an anode
okay good now that means that if i hook
those are two pieces of metal
two pieces of metal and if i hook them
up to a voltage supply
right then i can get charge
on them we know that already but what
they didn't understand
is what happened next you see because if
you crank the voltage up
really high and you put a phosphor
screen here
so this was a phosphor screen
and if you crank the voltage up high
enough and this is what thompson did
you pump the gas out of it right so you
get it so there's not too much stuff in
there
then what happens is something shot
across
and lit up this screen something
what they really didn't know and when
you don't know
you experiment and you apply the
scientific method and one of the things
that
thompson did is he said well what if i
put some
charge plates here like this
and this so i have a i have a set right
so i
said this is going to have charge that
flies off we know that because we kind
of know what happens
but he didn't know what was happening
he's just cranking the voltage up
and all of a sudden the screen lights up
so he's like well let me put some
charged plates here
and see what happens and what happened
there is
it went like this right and it made
a it struck the phosphor screen there
and it glowed there
so that's with charge with charge
plates right
no charge plates just to be
perfectly clear right and he could play
with this
right and people do play with this to my
great surprise if you
go onto the internet and you google
this you find people make these and play
with them
and that's a magnet this is what it
looks like right there's
that we didn't know what this was
right so so that's a magnet and and this
this person is just turning over whether
you know which part of the magnet
where the magnetic field is oriented and
you can see you can really mess with
this
what could it be it's responding to an
external field it's responding to an
external field so we know
right away this tells us
that atoms are not
the ultimate
form of matter
atoms were not the ultimate form of
matter that was a big deal because
you know the atoms here were neutral
they didn't respond so this must be
something else
that's flying off and responding that i
can see visually
on this photographic plate it must be
something else
well he was also thompson was uh
oh ha
going down here and i'm gonna use this
so it's right next to it
he was not able to measure the mass
of these things but he was able using a
combination of
magnetic right and electric fields
and a little bit of maxwell some e m he
was able to deduce the charge
to mass ratio so this falls over here
i'll put it here
from from thompson
so he was able to get the charge
to mass ratio
and he was able to measure that at minus
1.76
times 10 to the 11th
coulombs per kilogram now he knew it was
negatively charged because
of this right he put the plates on and
it wanted to avoid
the negative plate so we knew they knew
they knew their e
m at the time they knew that the
negative charges would repel
so he knew that it was negative charge
now the last thing oh
is this one important for chemistry
he would swap in different materials
different metals for the cathode and
for the cathode especially and the
results were the same
the results were the same ho ho
independent in dependent
of metal
independent of the metal that meant
this thing that he was observing for the
first time was fundamental there's
something fundamental
about it fun
fundamental fundamental
this was a really big deal this was a
really big deal and it
and it it really opened up the idea
that the atom had something else in it
now thompson see thompson knew
right he knew that
the atom was neutral like i said so you
got these charge things coming off
of these atoms which are neutral that
means that it must consist of these
charged particles but if it's neutral
it's got to have the other charge
of particle in it as well and so the
detective story goes on
so this would be thompson around
18 oh things really picked up
1807 and he said well okay
these electrons must be inside of the
atom
that's how i'm liberating them crank up
the voltage
and and they must be in there but so
much positive charges
it's almost positive charges okay and
that was thompson's model so at that
time
you could you could uh you could really
have this picture of stuff inside the
atom now like i said
he still he couldn't measure they didn't
have a scale
good enough to measure the mass of the
electron he couldn't get it out
right but it was it was milliken
and his very famous
experiments called the oil drop
experiments that gave us
the actual charge and then from this
ratio
we could get the mass of this this
mystery thing
that was coming out of atoms okay and
instead of drawing
uh uh uh trying to draw the milliken
experiment
i found a wonderful short like one ish
minute video
which i'll play because it shows how the
milliken experiment worked
it's really cool oh working at the
university of chicago
succeeded in measuring the charge on the
electron that's not happening
to settle through a hole into a chamber
where he could observe their fall
the top and bottom of the chamber
consisted of electrically charged plates
he introduced a source of x-rays which
can cause creation
charges when they strike matter charges
reduced by the x-rays attached to an oil
droplet
producing one or more charges on the
droplet
when there is no voltage applied the
fault the droplets
is determined by the mass and the
viscosity of air through which they fall
when a voltage is applied the droplets
that have a negative charge will fall
more slowly
stop falling or even rise depending on
the number of charges on them
by adjusting the applied voltage and
observing the droplets both with voltage
off
and voltage on milligan was able to
determine that the charges on the
droplets
were all multiples of a smallest value
1.6
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs
he took this to be the charge on a
single electron
all right so now you can see that that
would have been i hope that was
uh could you hear that in the back sort
of okay
all right oh i got the i got this it's
good
i i uh i you know that would have been
hard for me to draw the animation
but what a brilliant experiment right so
spray some oil
in a container okay try to get the drops
small you don't know how small they're
gonna be
and then as they okay have a have an
electric field inside there
and then as they fall zip them zap them
to charge them
you also don't know how much charge
you're putting on them
right but you're charging them and if
they're charged and they're in a field
and they're
these tiny little microscopic droplets
of oil they're going to maybe slow down
or suspend or maybe
go the other way and what he observed by
doing this over and over again that
there was some multiple that you never
got
below right and and you couldn't say
necessarily for
100 certainty that it was the
fundamental charge deduction might have
been a multiple of that but it was
pretty clear
it could never get below that so that
was the charge discovery
in this detective story and it allowed
us to understand that
the electron had a mass and it had
a charge and that we knew both of them
at the time so at the time then
we had um we already had a much deeper
understanding if you think about it
just four years later than the time of
dalton
because of these two experiments yeah
to huh alive
i read i think i read my uh he was ahead
of his time
thank you very much i think i read this
wrong and that's because i i don't have
my glasses on
so now that i look at that it wasn't
that uh small of a distance
thank you very much
you make mistakes you make mistakes and
you
that is how you learn
you don't make progress
progress has not almost nothing to do
with success i mean this
i'm using my own mistake here as an
example progress has almost nothing to
do with success
progress has only to do with what you
choose to do with failure somebody just
say whoa
thank you thank you that hit me here
all right okay let's do it why this
matters let's see why this matters
why does this matter well because see
these guys were trying to figure out
what was inside of an atom
but other people like john baird said
well wait a second you just gave me a
paintbrush
you gave me a paintbrush look at this
that's a paintbrush
painting with a magnet it really is and
the screen would light up over here
and so so he said well i can paint i can
paint pictures
and this really is the first television
screen this was the first tv screen
and and all they needed to do there okay
right there it is that's a cathode rim
tube
maybe that's one of thompson's students
who
won a nobel prize and and you put but
now you put this down
and you put these sort of things around
it what are those things magnetic fields
that's all it is
it's just magnetic fields it's
thompson's experiments right
but now they're using it
to zip the beam around faster than your
eyes can keep up with
so that it looks like a picture now
electron painting
had never been done before because we
didn't know
that we had these electrons but as soon
as we knew
boy did that launch a completely new era
of screens right the era
of screens we we don't use cathode ray
tubes don't say ask your grandparents
they'll tell you about the cathode ray
tube tvs
which they all had um but
you know we don't use cathode ray tubes
to paint with electrons today
in that way but we still paint with
electrons today
right your oled screen is still
simply an electron based painting tool
right right okay we're just pumping the
electrons into the phosphor
in a different way right and we'll be
talking about that
uh as we go through the rest of this
week and we understand how electrons
interact with light coming in and out of
an atom
okay so that's my why this matters and
by the way a side note here is that
when tvs first came along it
you know green was pretty easy there
were a lot of chemistries that were used
for this screen
right you put a different chemistry here
and it lights up differently
when electrons hit it why wait until
wednesday
green was easy yellow was easy red was
hard red was hard
they couldn't get a good red and um and
of course
uh and and that's why there were no
that's essentially the reason there were
no color tvs
until the 60s right um
and the answer of course was here the
answer was
that there was a phosphor that worked
but it was yitrium
orthovanadate with a little bit of
europium added to it
just a little bit of europium why did
that work again we need to understand
how electrons interact with matter which
is where we're going
and speaking of yitrium speaking of
yitrium
this is also a side story but it's kind
of worth noting you know
elements are named often elements can be
named after many things
all right in this case it was named
after guturbee sweden
turvy sweden is a pretty cool place they
have this one
cave you gotta go to it it's really cool
because four elements of the periodic
table were all discovered from uturby
sweden
in this one cave four and i keep
thinking
where is that cave in cambridge
they can't they cannot discover any more
elements because there's no other way
to mess with the name youtubey
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
that's a cool cave
that's worth visiting all right so the
structure of the atom
in 1900 thank you for the date
correction 1900
the structure of the atom was as follows
right
the atom is electrically neutral
but there are these negative charges
these negative charges called electrons
the electron has a very small mass we
know that from the oil drop experiments
right which means that the bulk of the
atom is positive because the bulk of the
mass of the atom right
you know the atom weighs one thing the
electron is just a small part of that in
terms of the mass
so most of the mass is positive
and there was a question okay so we're
getting somewhere
but how do these charges really look
how do these charges arrange inside of
this atom is thompson really right and
that was the next part of our detective
story
was to really understand what these
charges are doing inside the ad i'm
carrying this around like my security
blanket
which is making me feel very secure
right now and you should all carry it
too
this part of the story relies on another
type
of energy that was being discovered at
the time
and you all may recognize this as
radiation
now radioactivity
radio activity
is nothing more than ray
activity this is what they named it
after
reactivity
that's radioactivity and it was these
three people who really pioneered
the understanding type of radioactivity
and in particular
the fact that some elements seem to just
be radioactive what did that mean well
it means they gave off these rays
of energy it means they gave off these
rays of energy
you had henry becquerel you had
mary curie and pierre curie notice i
didn't even try where's jerome
i didn't even try with the french but
anyway they took these materials like
uranium ore
right minerals made out of uranium and
they said this stuff looks like it's got
some
something coming off of it let's see if
we can find what elements are causing
that
right and and marie curie won uh she
she found uh polonium and radium this
way those two elements polonium named
after her home
uh uh country her native country of
poland
um and and this stuff was so it gave off
all these all this energy
and it was so interesting they could
literally put it in a cup and have some
writing there
and put it in a super dark room and it
would illuminate the picture
right it would illuminate the picture
but this is not a recommended
way to light your pictures so
so pierre carried
a a vial of radium
because it was so cool and it glowed it
goes like he was like look at this stuff
right and he actually did have uh
bouts of radiation poisoning although he
died tragically
when he was struck by a horse-drawn
carriage in 1906
marie lived uh much longer and won two
belt but but also died because of
radiation poisoning
but uh she won two nobel prizes
first woman to win a nobel prize uh only
woman to win two
and for only person ever to win one in
two different
uh disciplines physics and chemistry she
was quite a brilliant
uh scientist um and they gave us this
radiation now
okay but see okay they were really into
radiation
but it was rutherford who said well wait
a second
maybe i can use this stuff to keep going
along this
story right rutherford was like well
maybe there's something we could do with
this radiation
and so
what happened oh there it is and so i'm
gonna put it right above it so you can
see so he said well okay
if i take some something that glows
maybe some radium and i carve out a
little thing here
and maybe i put some plates to kind of
protect
scatter i can make a beam of this stuff
okay so this would be like maybe radium
let's say
and then what he did is he took this
photographic plate and he curved it just
so you could really collect
as much as you could right so you can
really collect
you know really high angles and he did
the same thing
he put charged plates on either side
and he found that you had
three different types of beams you had
one that went like this
one that went like this and one that
went like this and we now
know that this is beta this is gamma
and that's alpha let's put this right
above
this is so cool to watch the you know so
what what rutherford did
is kind of like this he had stuff and he
made a beam of it
and then he he put he put stuff around
it
hey but if you got a beam of something
that might be charged you're not going
to smash it or burn it you're going to
put some plates around it right or a
magnetic field or electric field and
that's what he did
and notice alpha bends down
towards the positive chart towards the
negative charge so alpha must
be positively charged i said okay that
sounds cool
maybe i can use this maybe i can use
this
on this on this question of how these
things are spatially distributed
so then he said okay let's just screen
out those alpha particles
let's just take these alpha particles
and let's shoot them
so now comes the famous experiment so
you had stuff in here
radium making a beam and you you collect
it and you make it just
alpha particles okay so now he's just
got all alpha particles
and what he did is he also had a
photographic
uh plate or this could also be a
phosphorus screen and you could watch
where
you know if it's a photographic plate
you record things that you know events
and you can see it like a picture right
a film if it's a screen then you watch
it
right either one was used
but what he did is he put a very thin
strip
of gold in there 0.7
microns
of gold so that's a 0.7
thickness is 0.7 microns really really
thin like a tissue paper of gold
and he shot these alpha particles at it
now why is this important
because it goes in tight
because if this model
of the atom was correct then you know
he'd isolated these positive particles
that he's shooting at these atoms and if
that model of the
of the atom is correct then those you
know this is kind of like distributed
all over
right and so it's kind of neutral almost
anywhere you look
it's kind of neutral and and so you
would expect
that that a positive charge would maybe
feel a little bit but it's kind of feels
mostly neutral because it's evenly
distributed so it just kind of come out
but that's not what he saw
that's not what he saw what he saw is
that sometimes
that would happen and get a little bit
of deflection
and other times you'd get a signal out
here
or there or even right back at
the radium how is that possible
this did not work that model of the atom
did not work and rutherford himself said
it was almost as incredible as if you
fired a 15-inch shell at a piece of
tissue paper and it came back and hit
you
because this is they just didn't expect
that that a positive particle could
bounce backwards off of an even
distribution of charge
and so oh this is a picture from your
textbook april that i know you're
actively reading
on a daily basis so there's the alpha
particles that's what i drew that they
would expect
or what i mentioned they would expect it
to just kind of pass through
this is what was found where they kind
of come back
at very sharp angles that's what he
actually observed
right and it led to
the rutherford adam and the rutherford
adam
was that look the only way that this can
happen
you know that you get these events where
a positive charge comes back like that
is if there's a very very strong
concentration of the positive charge
in one small place and so he
said let me see if i can read my date
correctly 19
12. and so rutherford
he said
that the positive charge has to be in
the middle
and then the electrons must be
far away and that
is also sometimes it was called the
planetary uh
model and in fact there was another
scientist from japan
uh nagayoka who five years earlier had
predicted
although he sort of predicted this
because he loved saturn
he really did so he said you know it
seems
that um that that maybe we have a saturn
situation he called it the saturnian
model but i want to mention it because
it was
it it was part of the way there
right but in this planetary model which
came
from rutherford's experi experiments you
had a very different picture now
of the atom you had a very different
picture you had all the positive charge
really concentrated um in the middle
now um the thing is also
that the atom what they were starting to
understand is that the atom isn't just
like there isn't just all this space
here
right they they knew the electrons
weren't distributed evenly in here they
knew they were sort of far away
there's a lot of space there's a lot of
space
the the radius of the atom is a hundred
thousand
times bigger than the radius of the
nucleus
right um and so just to put that in
perspective right so here's a picture
there would be like the nucleus the head
of a pin and this would be the atom
a stadium now okay
if you took all the stuff
all the stuff in a human body that means
the protons
right the the uh all all the stuff in
the nuclei
the neutrons oh i'm getting there
and the electrons and you take all you
take seven billion people and you put
that all into one
volume it is the volume of a sugar cube
so you know so things are pretty empty
out there
things are pretty empty out there how
empty are they but this is where you
find true meaning
this is deep how empty is stuff look
i if i weigh the universe it you know
the universe itself
we're going from the atom and the
electron all the way up to the universe
the universe weighs something like oh 10
to the 60ish
kilograms that's over
roughly 30 billion light years
okay now if you just do the math right
so you weigh the universe
you know how big it is roughly plus or
you know give her mine
plus or minus then that means
that 10 to the minus 20
percent of the whole universe
is stuff
and the rest is empty
that's that's deep because we find
meaning in all of it don't we
that's deep think about that that comes
that's
not just the universe but the atom it's
the same you know
so much of everything is nothing
okay planetary but there was a problem
with the planetary model
there was a big problem with the
planetary model
because classical e m
told us that if it it you know if a
charge is accelerating
right if a charge is accelerating which
it is because it's
we think it's going around we think
they're going around here
they're not friday we'll know more about
that
but we thought they were but if it's
accelerating
you know to keep the the circle then
it's got to be radiating energy
that's what classical e m tells us an
accelerating charge loses energy
so so like if you go with that then
the electron uh let's see the stability
analysis
that we get out of something like that
hang on is uh that the the atom
would be stable
for ish 10 to the minus
11 seconds yeah
five times roughly
that's not giving us a lot of time
right and so we were getting so far we
had this great
model but it didn't go with classical e
n
so adam stable for that
with classical e m oh ho
because you know what's coming
we're going quantum not now i'm just
preparing you
for late did i hear an all thank you
friday
okay so boar comes along and on
wednesday we're really gonna
we're really gonna go into bore and
we're gonna talk about how bohr's model
how bohr's model of the atom allowed us
to understand
how light and matter interacts that's a
big deal
right um uh but we'll go into that on
wednesday for now i just want to tell
you what he did
which is he he thought about this
problem a lot
and he's like this can't be all right
we need some way out of this and he
wrote this paper
um where he said the following oh
he said let's go over here he said uh
okay
in order to explain the results of
experiments on
scattering of alpha rays we just did
that
scattering of alpha rays by matter
professor rutherford has given
a theory of the structure of atoms and
then
boar goes on and he says
great interest is to be attributed to
this atom model
now that is a serious dis
great interest if somebody calls your
model
of great interest you know you're in
trouble
that's basically he might as well have
said back then
you know this model is of great interest
because it's totally wrong
and if you want to know what's up come
over to me and i'll tell you
and that's what poor helped with um in
his work and what he
what he did is he wrote down some
postulates
he said look the rutherford adam is
correct
but the problem here is classical e m
theory
right you cannot apply classical e
m theory to the orbiting electron you
can't
because that's what happens so
something's wrong with literally
nothing less than classical physics
right
he said newtonian mechanic still works
right newtonian mechanics works
but not e m she said we can go classical
on how things are moving around
f equals m a stuff but not e m
um he also postulated that the energy
of these electrons the energy that these
electrons
sit at or have we'll get into this a lot
he posit he hypothesized that that's
quantized
quantized quantized
we're saying that word it's a beautiful
moment quantized
quantize means that it could only have
certain values
certain values which means that if this
electron were to be in one value and
then
change into another that that the
transitions
are quantized the transitions of an
electron from one
energy of the at one energy level of the
atom to another
can only have certain values and that is
what we get from the bohr model
and boy did it explain things that's
what that's going to be the subject of
wednesday
as i mentioned right but this gets us to
to the bore
model and here's boar
where now oh i got to draw this we got
all the positive charge in the middle
and then
these electrons can only have certain
radii certain energies they cannot
continuously roam around
they can't they're quantized that's the
bohr model
and this is closed in 1912.
this is closing in on
the last and final model which we'll get
to this week which is where quantum
mechanics comes in
okay now i we got one more thing to talk
about right so we'll we'll be
this is where we're going we're building
up the full understanding of the atom
um but there's one more thing that i got
to come back to
and that is that look we just said there
are these positive charges in there and
these negative charges out there
but it turns out that atoms can have
different masses
and stay neutral all right so we're now
in a position to talk about this thing
that we've been calling the nucleus and
the fact that it's not
just protons we're in a position to talk
about that
and so you know rutherford gave us this
uh this idea of the proton the particle
the proton
and it wasn't until 12 years later
that chadwick found the neutron
what what the neutron does is
it adds mass to the atom
see the mass didn't work right so again
you know if you know what the mass the
proton is
then you can add it up and you got the
mass of the electron although it's
pretty you know it's like a thousandth
as much but it doesn't work there's
there's something else in there that's
adding mass but it's not adding charge
because these things are electrically
neutral
so those other particles are called
neutrons and
and what it does is it gives us ranges
of masses for the atoms right it gives
us ranges
so so because you know hydrogen now we
might
we might think about it 99.99 of all
hydrogen
is just that thing on the left a proton
and an electron
but sometimes it has a neutron so it
weighs more it's still got neutral
charge it's called deuterium and
and then you've got tritium which isn't
stable you can make it
and these are called isotopes as many of
you i'm sure already know
these are called isotopes
and so the isotopes of an
atom the isotopes
have atom
with the same atomic number
different
number of neutrons
right different number of neutrons so so
atoms have these three things in them
they've got the neutrons the protons and
the electrons we've been talking today
about the protons in the electrons but
they got to have these other things in
them where the mass doesn't work
and so if you look at
something like carbon you see the same
thing and now i want to get into how
how these things are written right
because
so in car here's carbon and there are
those electrons they're now put out
there okay we didn't draw a circle so
maybe this is
maybe this is around rutherford's time
when april made this picture and there's
the pluses and there's
other things in there right and those
are the neutrons
and so what we do is we have a
nomenclature for this
which is the standard and that is that
if we write an element like this right
this would be the element
and we put something here and something
here
this is the mass number
okay so that's how many that's protons
plus neutrons
new ah neutrons
and this is called the atomic number
now the atomic number i've been
referencing this thing this atomic
number i said
mendeleev and many others they put
things in order
of you know atomic number maybe mass
sometimes
mendeleev did the thing where he did
those things and
properties right the atomic number was
just a number
until later and and once we discover
another type of ray x-rays then
this has real physical meaning right but
right now it's still just a number it's
the number
of the element in the periodic table
right but that mass number tells me
uh whether i have you know how many
neutrons i have and what what the
isotope is so now i go back
i can go back and i can look at carbon
oh by the way carbon i wanted to write
this down
before i say that carbon when you look
it up in the ta
in the table you have 12 12.011
amu or grams per mole that's what's in
in the table
but now you know why because it's just
an average
and in fact the iupac which is a rocking
body of
the international union of pure and
applied chemistry i'm sure you've seen
them on the feeds
they hold meetings and in vienna a
non-stop night
of intense meeting and partying
and and they said hey maybe in 2011
maybe we should actually do this with
the periodic table just to show that
actually
there really is a range if i did carbon
out of the ground here the carbon out of
the ground there
maybe they have different amu's right
these are averages
and there are ranges so they're actually
talking about uh different ways
of even putting this into periodic
tables
right um but but this is and this gets
us to
back oh there's boring and nitrogen
ranges
right but what we do now at least is we
just look at
uh the one number because that's sort of
averaged over
you know basically anywhere you can dig
this stuff up and the stable
isotopes stable isotopes and it gets me
to
my last uh slide which just comes back
to the beginning as i promised
right because now i can say not only how
many gallium atoms are in this strip but
i can tell you gallium has two stable
isotopes by the way it's got a bunch of
unstable ones
but it's got two stable ones gallium 69
and gallium 71
and i can now ask you how many gallium
69 atoms are in this trip
how because i can again
look up in the periodic table
and find that
in a gallium strip i know how many atoms
i have
but if i say well 69 times x
plus 71 times 1 minus
x that's going to equal 69.723
amu that's what's in the periodic table
but i now know that that's simply an
average over
all the right so this would be like the
fraction
of 69 ga
right because that's how simple these
isotope problems are right it's simply
averaging over
the potentially stable isotopes and i
leave you with with one
more great mystery as you are pondering
this think about this
there are two elements ah
there are two elements for which there
are no stable isotopes
technetium and promethium nothing
technetium we use all the time 80 of all
mris use technician but it's not stable
we gotta make it
right that's pretty deep too how did
that happen why did that happen
for the answer you'll have to stay tuned
have a good night
and see you guys on wednesday
you